Chelsea Manning was jailed this week
with an indefinite sentence until as the
Virginia judge said she purges about the
circumstances over revealing to the
world the extent of NATO nation war
crimes her case arguably encompasses
philosophical concepts of the NATO
military industrial complex ranging from
freedom to neo colonialism to the
illusion of consumer choice I'm joined
now via Skype from Ljubljana by one of
the world's most popular living
philosophers Slavoj Zizek now my welcome
to growing underground before we get on
to philosophical concepts and the rest
of the news your thoughts about Chelsea
Manning the former intelligence
operative he was of course tortured we
had PJ Crowley over the State Department
talking about that
she's been jailed again what do you
think I think it's a clear sign of the
desperate tendency of the American
establishment to get Julian Assange as
the prosecutor whatever because what
they are putting pressure on her is to
give more data about how she was
contacted with WikiLeaks men three or at
that point he made public the data he or
she collected and so on and so on so I
see this as part of this ongoing getting
stronger and stronger campaign against
WikiLeaks and I think this when people
talk about liberal freedoms and so on
and so on Julian Assange maker made many
mistakes but his great immortal even
contribution is to make us aware of the
extent to which we are controlled
manipulated and shown and so on for me
the best friends of Julian Assange is
Google is just a private corporate
version of NSA now people criticize us
always for not attacking Russia more
cynical here and nobody be like my
answer but in Russia you have an incline
a certain sense that you don't live in a
western-style totally liberal country
it's important to show how you are
controlled in America because they
believe fully in their freedom they
think they are free and the more you
think you are free what can be more free
than sharing on the web and shown the
more tightly you are control that's the
miracle of of these digital forms of
control
they don't even appear as an external
force that is controlling you
that's why a socialist to be cashed and
that's why the establishment mobilized
all its forces I compete no discount
even a big public media which are
considered more on the left like in
United Kingdom The Guardian they are
merciless lately in their animosity
against you had to Julian Assange under
arbitrary detention here of course in
London and his work on Google but this
week the British government says that
these powerful tech companies it's more
a question of consumer choice whenever
people say freedom of choice I am in
this year and they say you know let
lemon scent allegedly about freedom yes
freedom but freedom for whom to do what
the question today's yes freedom of
choice but freedom of whom to choose
what what are our actual choices my
metaphor here is that most of the
choices that media present us with our
choices in the style of do you want Diet
Coke or Diet Pepsi these are choices
within a certain level consumerist level
and we should move out of this through
political even intimate choices much
more of course you also been writing
about the facts that those who perhaps
sympathize with that they've kind of
failed I mean you mentioned syriza of
course in Greece the cradle of Western
democracy the u.s. continuing war in
Venezuela we've had anti-semitism smears
here against Jeremy Corbyn left-leaning
congresswoman accused of these things
yet you say that actually there's no
need to be pessimistic
yes I agree with what you said I think
this is a very sad lesson for those who
still want to be less
today it's all too easy to invest all
energy into criticizing the new old
right Trump in the United States and so
on and so on but we should never forget
that this new and immigrant nationalist
populism is the result of the failure of
the liberal democratic center or even
left center i think the establishment is
becoming aware of this which is why it's
modern more moving to those at least
minimally authentic leftists who
questioned also the liberal
establishment what happens lately in the
united states on going even feminist
attacks on bernie sanders who also is
really a little bit out of the frame of
what establishment allows and that's my
point
crazy as it may sound the true battle
today is not we open liberal
multiculturalist whatever verses
neo-fascist right know the truth
struggle today in united state
politically the struggle which will
maybe decide the fate of the country is
what goes on in the democratic party
my favorite saying of mao zedong there
is great disorder under heaven so the
situation is excellent
it's my optimism the situation is open
there is no ruling consensus in such a
situation we shouldn't get as liberals
do into a panic oh my god let's all
unite against fascist red we should
retain our cool yet and see for the
opportunities how we can use this
situation keep something in the
direction of a more radical left Slav oh
I'm gonna stop you there more from
Professor Slovakia shake after this
break
[Music]
welcome back I'm still with philosopher
Slav oho check it as we said that one
response to people who talk about
progress say the problem is actually
fake news you've used the phrase
uncontrollable plurality what fake news
they're nothing new
let's return to the era of the Cold War
we had two big narratives Western
liberal narrative Soviet communist
narrative both well in the sense in some
sense one big fake news story so I think
what don't be in the establishment worry
when they deploy fake news is not lies
as such it's more that it's no longer
one central line that they can control
you know always certain ideological
narrative story there is nothing
postmodern in this so here I would
correct those who deplore fake news the
most effective and dangerous lies lies
which operate with partial truth you
collect some data which are undoubtedly
true and you organize them into a
narrative weak list in itself like so
you know there is no easy way out here
like oh we will tell you just just the
truth and so on and so on but the Trump
thinks news is so important in the media
you think that say in the case of
Venezuela fake news from near liberal
media wouldn't be enough to overthrow
the Bolivarian revolution it does still
require military action I quoted again
Stalin who will ask which with deviation
is worse in 29 I think right-wing or
less this deviation he said both are
worse I think both sides are worse at
the present situation in Venezuela but
you know what's so dangerous about guy
dog of course coordinated with United
States
machinery auntie Maduro
and it's again the element of truth in
it there are food troubles in Venezuela
there probably are great problems with
with police oppression and so on and so
on that's what makes it relatively
effective it is true that millions that
Venezuela and so on and so on so again I
repeat my point is the most dangerous
fake news in the sense of false
ideological politically motivated
propaganda is propaganda which
manipulates the truth which uses
elements of truth okay well you blame I
mean you inherently blame Maduro their
part revenge
yes yes it's obvious you cannot put
that's my sad position I think the basic
problem that I see with Maduro
intolerable Travis is not this liberal
topic corruption or whatever it's a very
sad man message that even Travis already
and especially Maduro they didn't
deliver in constructing finding offering
to the people through alternative models
they made all possible experiment with
social property alternatives and so on
and so on so it's not just moralist
criticism it's a very sad lesson about
today's more radical left they don't
really have feasible model I thought you
actually praised Chavez for all those
different attempts but I'm gonna ask you
really already it was clear I followed
under Travis the situation closely it's
clear that he was just a lucky guy by
lucky
I mean having enough money from oil and
so on and so on
but the level of constructing a new
social space where production would have
been organized in the in a different way
from capitalism he failed and I think
now I will tell you another terrifying
thing I think that in some sense and
that's the big lesson of economic neo
colonialism today great not
resources can be a curse a great curse
claim that maybe if all of a sudden most
of the nacelles oil the immense oil
reserves would have disappeared maybe
tomorrow the world would lose interest
in Venezuela and maybe it's a more
modest level they would have found and
you all right but if I can just go to
the European Union obviously I mean what
do you if you were an advisor to the
British government would you be trying
to overturn the result of the referendum
and keep Britain in the European Union
or do you see the thousands drowning
tens of thousands drowning in the
Mediterranean little and the
imprisonment of cattle and politicians
mean no country could ever be part of
this institution
maybe our positions are different I'm
all the limitations of the bureaucracy
and so on and so on but they still think
that why then do is European Union so
universally traded perceived as a threat
I think that nonetheless in spite all of
this corruptions and so on and so on in
a differences bankers and so on and so
on
I think the way out is not black seed
black seed has a dangerous illusion
built in death today the way to liberate
ourselves from the control of the
national capital and Swansea on is to
return to a stronger nation state I
think this is a catastrophic formula ii
think many British people even friends
of mine claim we want to the less
supporters of black sea we want to cut
loose from Brussels which represents the
banking or financial regulations we want
to build a stronger well stir state and
so on and so on
wait a minute I remember Blair
government got in conflict with buses
Blair
that made us to protect the environment
the imposition of the maximal coming
hours workers should or should be
allowed to work in during the week and
so on and so on so but my point is this
one that why then is Europe bothering
everybody I think that the idea of
united Europe is still something not in
the present form but it has to be
changed of course is worth fighting for
it's a trans national institution and
isn't which tries to regulate things in
the sense of common welfare I think that
we we will need this more than ever
thanks how far would you how far would
you go with this reformist slovak
reformist agenda then obviously
thousands and thousands are dead or
injured on the streets of Paris over the
GLA John as I said well there are 3,000
injured at least 10 deaths linked with
the protests before today's GA John demo
ambiguous care for me it's easy to say
what you are saying weight is a minimal
program of yellow West they will sting
the wasting their time then being left
in peace they would help be able to
propose a consistent program no the
program is I claim totally inconsistent
because this is a very populist movement
in a traditional way I would be ready to
support yellow West but the way they are
moving now they they just move gradually
in the direction of some type some type
of almost intended to save marine lepen
populist nationalist politics I no
longer have distrust
that many less describe I call it a
Maoist rust into the wisdom of ordinary
people in the sense of where ordinary
people protest we should listen
to eat we can learn something from it
what was practiced in a nice way with
podemos in Spain the leader I'd like to
repeat forget about big ideological
issues listen to ordinary people today
trouble now in a very brutal way I'm
tempted to say we should listen just to
see how they are also imprisoned into
their own illusion we will not get
lesson a message of what to do by
listening to ordinary people's concerns
you've been criticized by ordinary
people for your saying a call for the
left to embrace its radical Western
roots as well as what you said about
refugees there are tens of thousands
drowned in the Mediterranean thanks to
the Cameron Sarkozy war in Libya this
problem
what made this exploitation of African
countries what happened in Syria in Iraq
the crisis and so on and so on if Europe
just opens up its borders then it will
be a catastrophe because at a certain
point let's be absolutely clear here we
will have to confront a very difficult
choice either immigrants are coming in
to throw in but in this case we have to
abolish democracy because the majority
of the people is clearly against it and
so on and so on so we have to radically
change the approach here not to limit
ourselves again to this humanitarian
aspect my god refugees are there let's
step back again and ask ourselves how we
are complicit in producing generating
situations which make refugees second
point nonetheless I will say something
that many people will not like Europe
did nonetheless at least Germany
received quite many refugees just look
at the numbers how many refugees are in
France not mentioned Germany Italy
nonetheless in spite of the horrors of
the ongoing politics what about other
countries to give you an example and
this is for me the ultimate obscenity in
in countries preserved only the poorer
countries Egypt and so on dick
Saudi Arabia Kuwait Bahrain Emirates
Qatar how many refugees did they accept
receive none what is going on there and
these same countries are approaching
Europe for its your century closure and
so on and so forth I'm not sure how many
refugees would like to be in those
countries arguably but I've got a
finally I gotta finish there with okay
think now because this sounds nice and
humanist but I think it's it's pretty
inconsiderate do you give if you give
the refugees the right to choose the
country that they want then you are too
much of a crazy communist even for me do
you think that the basic human right
today is that you can move to any
country of your choice and demand of
their country to take care of you I
think this means explosion this means
populist revolt in that country this is
not simply a realist option so you think
that the refugee is basically what they
can eat it and they want the welfare
state they want to be it's clear many of
them not all want to be integrated in
the sense of enjoying the benefits of
the developed Western countries but at
the same time it's clear that they don't
want cultural integration into the
western lifestyle I'm asking you what do
you have okay do you advocate that we
should be in Europe purely multicultural
in the sense of everybody can come and
go on with each their way of life but on
the other hand we should respect the
moment but when we demand the same of
for example our country's obvious number
4b and so on professor Slavoj Zizek
thank you and that's it for the show
will be back on Monday when we
investigate the alleged chemical attack
on Duma and the illegal NATO bombing
that followed with Syrian member of Paul
dr. Hamid Marais until then keep in
touch by social media Monday